[Music]
wealthy corporations and people love to
ask the question what can I do what
should we do
what can we start what program could we
launch I would say to the billionaire
change agents and and corporate
corporate social responsibility
departments of our country ask not what
you can do for your country ask what
you've already done to your country ok
before you want to start something of
your own a little private unaccountable
venture do an audit
what do you pay people you pay people
enough
do you use subcontractors to avoid
responsibility for those workers do you
pay benefits when do your benefits kick
in what do you lobby for in Washington
do you lobby for things that make
everybody have a better life in America
or do you lobby against social policies
that would cost you something what's
your tax avoidance situation are you do
you happen to be this earnest company
that that that wants to change the world
I mean is is this is this company paying
its full measure of taxes does it use
tax havens does it do the double dutch
with an irish sandwich tax maneuver does
it send money the cayman islands and
then back and do all this complex
routing if you're telling me that there
are companies that do none of this stuff
that pay people well that don't dump
externalities into the economy that
don't cause social problems if there are
such companies exist
yeah then once you've taken care of all
that great doing some some projects to
help people is great but I haven't found
very many such companies and more often
than not when companies do a lot of CSR
it's because they understand that
they're not on the right side of justice
in their day operations so they want to
do virtue as a side hustle and the
problem is a lot of these companies tend
to create harm and billions and then do
good in the millions and you don't need
to be a mathematician to know that we're
the losers from that bargain and you
look at the B Corp movement there's a
lot of companies that actually have an
interest in trying to invent a new kind
of company that is not predatory there's
in the B Corp movement a certification
process for those company
now the challenges of them is that it's
a great thing but it's fundamentally
voluntary and what this does is it means
that if you're you know on already good
virtuous Company you may be motivated to
get into this club but if you're Exxon
or Pepsi you know you're not gonna
you're not gonna be in this club one
things I'd like to see is how can we
actually use the power of public policy
to get more companies to sign up to
simply not dump harm social harm into
our society whether that takes the form
of toxic sludge or you know obese
children or workers with unpredictable
hours and income and in the B Corp we
have a model of a company that looks
different but we don't have any kind of
compulsion around it so you know senator
Elizabeth Warren has a proposal out to
turn every American corporation into a B
Corp as a condition for getting a
corporate charter I think there's a less
radical option that I sometimes talk
about which is why don't we just you
know have a different and lower
corporate tax rate for companies that in
a certifiable way don't dump huge social
problems onto the Commons and that that
way we might see thousands and thousands
of companies electing to become you know
certified benefit corporations in order
to avail of that lower tax rate I think
we have to start thinking about how we
attack one of the root causes of this
kind of greed and malfeasance in
American life which is shareholder
primacy and the fact that many companies
even ones that want to be better are at
risk of violating their shareholders
rights by doing so but I don't think we
can do that strictly by creating a
voluntary pool of better companies I
think we have to start using our
leverage of society to say if you want
the benefits that we as a society give
you when you become a corporation here's
what we want in return
[Music]